sandi starts off of this hour in Olympia
Washington hi sandy welcome to the Dave
Ramsey show
good afternoon Dave I'm actually two
hours west of Olympia in a little town
called Ocean Shores cool how can I help
today well I wanted to build a detached
garage on my property for a long time
the little house doesn't have a garage
and currently that the house is worth
about I could probably sell it for 190
and I owe about 136 on it and in order
for me to to build the garage I would
need to refinance the house and and take
out of the equity enough to to do this
up to 20,000 they said I could do so my
question is would this be a good move
i'm unretired
you don't have any money no except for a
little bit in in savings right now not
much how old are you I'm 70 okay and
what's a little bit in savings what's
that mean $900 $900 to your name right
and what do you live on Social Security
and what else
my teacher retirement is about 25,000 a
year together plus sometimes I
substitute teach gotcha
so I usually make about thirty thousand
year how did you come to call me well
I've been listening to your show on the
radio occasionally and then I found you
online and I thought you know I was
looking at some things to maybe give my
grandchildren for graduation from your
$10 cell and I thought you know I'm
going to ask you this question because
how many grandchildren I got I know
three graduating in Gion two twins and a
stepson and I asked gross total
grandchildren yeah I'm gonna I'm gonna
send you three graduate Survival Guide
as my gift okay well thank you yeah we
appreciate you being a listener if
you've listened more than just a few
minutes you know I'm no debt Dave don't
you right right so you already know what
I'm gonna say don't you I do not want my
new 70 year old friend with $900 to go
further into debt okay I'd love for you
to have a garage but I love more that
you've got a very low house payment that
you can manage with the income that you
have coming in and you are you are a
frugal common-sense lady and you got a
little bit of garage fever going here
and yeah usually a good cold shower will
fix those favors all right darlin you
hold on we're gonna send you three
copies of that book to say thank you for
being a new listener and no I'm not
going to tell you to go further in debt
the last thing you need right now is
more debt you don't have any money
you're living carefully on the pension
and Social Security that you have you're
70 and you still have a mortgage so I
don't need you to have a bigger mortgage
that would further destabilize your life
so not worth the risk and stress it
could put on you I wouldn't do it